THIS IS MY WORLD.
[♪]
JUDGE JEANINE: HELLO AND WELCOME
TO "JUSTICE," I’M JUDGE JEANINE
PIRRO.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR GIVING
JUSTICE A HUGE AUDIENCE WITH
MORE THAN 3 MILLION PLUS VIEWERS
LAST SATURDAY.
SO TONIGHT AS WE GEAR UP FOR
SUPER BOWL SUNDAY, LET’S GO FOR
ANOTHER BIG SCORE.
ON THE FIELD TO HELP US GET
THERE TONIGHT, REPUBLICAN
CONGRESS MANAGE JIM JORDAN, MARK
MEADOWS AND DOUG COLLINS.
AS WELL AS SENATOR TOM COTTON
AND KIM LETTER BY STRASSEL FROM
THE "WALL STREET JOURNAL."
AND TRUMP CAMPAIGN MANAGER BRAD
PASSD --.I WANT TO TAKE THIS OPP
TO THANK OUR FRIENDS,
SPECIFICALLY DEMOCRATS NANCY
PELOSI, ADAM SCHIFF, JERRY
NADLER AND THE WHOLE UNHINGED
LOT OF THEM FOR GUARANTEEING THE
REELECTION OF PRESIDENT DONALD
JOHN TRUMP IN 2020.
THEIR NONSTOP HATE, HYPOCRISY
AND HYSTERIA HAS SO EXHAUSTED US
THAT WE HONESTLY CAN’T WAIT TO
THE RE-ELECT HIM AGAIN.
THEIR POLITICAL STUNTS HAVE BEEN
A CHOLESTEROL WASTE OF TIME AND
SEALED HIS REELECTION.
THOUGH TECHNICALLY IT HASN’T
HAPPENED YET.
YOU SENATORS HAD TO DRAG THIS
OUT UNTIL NEXT WEEK AND COULDN’T
WORK THROUGH THE WEEKEND.
WHY?
I KEEP ASKING MYSELF WHY THESE
DEMOCRATS KEEP MAKING LIARS AND
FOOLS OF THEMSELVES.
THE PRESIDENT IS A RUSSIAN
ASSET.
NO, SAYS ROBERT MUELLER.
THE PRESIDENT IS AN ILLEGITIMATE
OCCUPIER SAYS THE OVAL.
>> NO, SAYS THE ELECTORAL
COLLEGE.
THE PRESIDENT IS AS DESCRIBED IN
THE DOSSIER.
NO SAYS THE CHIEF JUDGE OF THE
FISA COURT AS WELL AS THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
THE PRESIDENT IS A RACIST.
NO, SAYS AFRICAN-AMERICAN
UNEMPLOYMENT AND BEN CARSON’S
OPPORTUNITY ZONE.
THE PRESIDENT WILL RUIN THE
ECONOMY.
NO SAYS THE STOCK MARKET OVER
AND OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
AND THE LATEST UKRAINE CLAIM?
NO SAYS THE BEST EVIDENCE, THE
REAL EVIDENCE, THE TRANSCRIPT.
AND SHIP * SAYS THE PRESIDENT --
ADAM SCHIFF SAYS THE PRESIDENT’S
MISCONDUCTING NOT BE DECIDED AT
THE BALLOT BOX BECAUSE QUOTE WE
CANNOT BE ASSURED THE VOTE WILL
BE FAIRLY WON.
ADAM, ARE YOU SIDE OR DO YOU
THINK WE ARE.
AREN’T YOU EMBARRASSED YET?
WHY THE DEMOCRAT PARTY,
ALLEGEDLY THE PARTY INCLUSION
AND OPENNESS IS AT THIS MOMENT
IN TIME THE MOST OBSTRUCTIVE,
NON-BELOW DEDUCTIVE -- BE NONE
PRODUCTIVE GROUP OF HATERS CAN
ONLY BE ATTRIBUTED TO THEIR KN
BE HATE.
HE’S ONLY OCCUPYING SPACE.
JUDGE JEANINE: THEY ARE LIKE A
BUNCH OF THUGS GANG UP TO
DESTROY THE PRESIDENT.
THEY USE IMPEACHMENT TO OVERTURN
THE WILL AND THE ELECTION OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THE FUNNY THING IS, THEY CALL
THE * A MONARCH, DICTATOR,
FASCIST.
BUT THEY ACCUSE THE PRESIDENT OF
DOING WHAT THEY DO EVERY DAY.
THEY HAVE THE CHUTZPAH TO
COMPLAIN ABOUT THE SENATE TRIAL
WHEN THEY HELD THEIR CASE IN A
STAR CHAMBER.
THEY SAY THE PRESIDENT’S CLAIM
OF EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE IS PROOF
OF HIS GUILT.
WHEN THE WHOLE POINT OF THE
EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE IS TO
PROTECT THE CONSTITUTION AND THE
SEPARATIONS OF POWERS.
THEY LOOK LIKE FOOLS FIGHTING TO
GET TO THE CAMERA FIRST TRYING
TO GET AS MUCH FACE TIME AS
POSSIBLE.
WATCH SCHIFF TRY TO PULL BACK
NADLER.
>> ANY OTHER COMMENTS THE SENATE
WOULD BEEN FROM IT HEARING
BEFORE WE ADJOURN FOR THE
EVENING?
>> MR. CHIEF JUSTICE, MEMBERS OF
THE SENATE.
JUDGE JEANINE: I THINK I WANT A
MORATORIUM ON THE I WORD.
I AM SO OVER IMPEACHMENT.
BUT I WON’T BE OVER WEDNESDAY,
THEY WILL DO IT AGAIN.
THEY WILL FIND ANOTHER SO-CALLED
WHISTLEBLOWER OR A FOREIGN AGENT
THEY WILL PAY TO MAKE UP LIES
ABOUT OUR PRESIDENT.
SO I SAY TO MYSELF, SELF, WHAT
ARE THESE FOOLS DOING IN
CONGRESS?
THEY COULD CARE LESS ABOUT USER.
>> IMMIGRATION OR HEROIN COMING
THROUGH THE SOUTHERN BORDERS.
THEY CAN’T EVEN GIVE THE
PRESIDENT CREDIT FOR TAKE OUT
TWO OF THE WORLD’S WORST
TERRORISTS IN A MATTER OF WEEKS
WITH KNOW COLLATERAL DAMAGE.
THE COMMISSION -- THE MILITARY
IS REBUILT, THE ECONOMY IS
SOARING.
I WANT TO THANK OUR FRIENDS THE
DEMOCRATS FOR TAKE OFF THEIR
MASK AND EXPOSING THEIR HATE,
THEIR CONDESCENSION AND THEIR
DISGUST FOR THE REST OF US.
I ALSO WANT TO THANK THE
DEMOCRATS FOR UNITING THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY EXCEPT FOR
MITT.
WE DIDN’T WANT MITT ANYWAY.
AND I WANT TO THANK DONALD
TRUMP.
NOT ONLY FOR TEACHING THE
REPUBLICANS FINALLY HOW TO
FIGHT, BUT FOR PUTTING UP WITH
THE NONSENSE THAT HE GOES
THROUGH EVERY DAY FOR THE REST
OF US TO MAKE AMERICA GREAT.
AND THAT’S MY OPEN.
LET ME KNOW WHAT YOU THINK ON MY